what is the trick of sustaining such a  deep good relationship in such a busy  life  you can ask every working woman that  question and get a million different  answers because it's it's the juggle and  the the challenge that we have but  honestly in my life because it's in the  arts I don't go to work every day so my  my days been more flexible than other  working women even when I was young and  broke I could I was only working ever  for four months at a time then I was  unemployed hmm so my children never knew  when I was going to be home was very  valuable but you know I think it's I  think it's it's a struggle and we it's  an ongoing struggle women women have to  do it all you know and so the more  flexible work becomes the more engaged  the dads become the better